Alright, so before we're giving you the example, I want to show you the market make a buy model as well a depiction of it
So similarly what you will have is you will have your POI right there. So you can see there's a POI and
You once price comes into your one hour
Sorry a daily POI you want to drop down to the one hour time frame, right?
once you have like a
Once price comes into your POI right you want to start identifying or sniping or scouting the original consolidation
So when was the first consolidation before price started moving towards your POI, right?
So if this was the consolidation, right? I will show you how to identify them. Don't worry
I'll show you the examples tons of examples
So then that would be absolutely clear
But you simply look for a consolidation phase one and then a consolidation phase two
This one is not necessary, but it is gonna as I said before it's gonna make your win rate even higher
price comes into your POI
Now remember the time from alignment from daily to one hour to five minutes. So once you get a market structure shift your
Bias or like your setup is gonna be like officially active
Okay, because you have a market structure shift if you don't have a market structure shift
If you are not doing anything, but you're just identifying the consolidation, right? You're identifying the market maker buy model
But once you get a market structure shift one
Simple thing you don't enter from here, right? And target try to target these levels. However
You don't have to hold till here because we don't know what's price gonna do, right?
We are just only putting the probabilities in play like we have high probability of course
But price can simply take out, you know, like let's say this high over here this consolidation and then reverse
So you have to take partials along the way
You have to trail your stop loss or you have to go break even at some point. It all depends on your trading style
So remember the mitigation blocks, right?
Price if price gives you an entry, right?
You are you can take longs
So if there's a fairly gap on auto block inside this mitigation block
Which is an old auto block a bearish auto block you take your entry from there. Let's say price breaks through this level this
Medication block there's fairly gap on auto block inside there you take entry from there and you go there simple as that
but
Once you get a market structure shift, right? You want to mark out your
This range low and this range high
So now once price comes into your one hour POI
You drop down to five minute time frame and then you start looking for consolidation on the five minute time frame around here
the original consolidation, right and then let's say you have another consolidation and
Price came into your POI, right?
You then look for a market structure shift on the five minute time frame once again
So that's let's say price comes into your one hour auto block or any POI
Oh my god, let me disable this error bro
It's making the chart so messy. So on the five minute
Let's say price comes into the one hour auto block or POI you get a market structure shift
And you have the original consolidation with a second consolidation you take your entry and I bet you it's gonna hit the take profit
It's really that simple. I mean, it's a little complicated
But I'm gonna show you the examples and then it will become very simple for you